in a documentary you started singing
acapella Amazing Grace yeah boy is that
powerful I so badly want you to do that
you just sing it without a guitar you
just go right into it yeah well I saw
Avengers end the shows uh playing this
this Irish folk song I mean I can sing
it I can I can sing it now if you want
yeah I love it but it's um
um it's more of a like it's like a
passing song and then after that I went
into Amazing Grace because that's what
um was sung at Jamal's funeral but it's
more of a it's more of a like lament to
say goodbye in general but
[Music]
um
uh
I
spent it in Good Company
let it done
all I see it was too none but me
and all I've done
for once of which
to memory now I can't recall
so fell to me
The Parting Glass
good night and joy be with you all
and of all the comrades
they are sorry for my going
away
and all the Sweethearts
they would wish me one more day
's day
but since it falls
unto my Lord
that I should rise and you should not
I'll gently rise and I'll softly cold
good night enjoy be with you wonder man
May drink
and not be drunk
a man May fight and not be slain
a man May quarter pretty girl
and perhaps be welcome back again
but since it has
so what to be
by a time to rise and a time to fall
Come Fill to me the partying gloves
good night enjoy be with you with you
all
uncomfortable to me the party English
[Music]
Amazing Grace
how sweet
the sound
that saved
rich like me
and I once was lost
but now
I'm found
was blind but now
I see
yeah it was kind of like fusing both
like I grew up in Irish cultures so that
sort of like closing song of anything
would be The Parting Glass and being at
that that funeral I mean it's it's so
powerful like um Jamal's mum's a a
singer and a performer and seeing her
and her her aunt like through real pain
just bring music into it and having
we're all set standing by this this
grave site and everyone singing Amazing
Grace together it was like it was really
powerful